[موسيقى]
لم أتمكن من رؤية إلفيس ،
لكنني رأيت ثلاث تجمعات رابحة أنا في
حفلة مراقبة ليلة الانتخابات لمؤيدي ترامب
في ميدان هورون فالي
في ميشيغان ،
نحن متجر محافظ
جدًا ووطنيون جدًا
ونحن  من الواضح أنه مؤيد للغاية لترامب
وهي مجرد فرصة للأشخاص ذوي التفكير
المماثل للالتقاء معًا والقدرة على
التحدث بحرية تفكيرهم دون القلق
بشأن
شخص ما يضايقه ، فلماذا أنت
هنا الليلة
أنا هنا الليلة للاستمتاع
بآمل إعادة  - انتخاب دونالد ترامب لرئيسنا ،
ما الذي ستفعله إذا فاز بايدن
بنفس الشيء الذي فعلته عندما فاز أوباما
بامتصاص ترامب لن يخسر ،
ضع علامة عليّ على هذا الذي وضعه في مكانه مقابل
316.
مربى ورقة رابحة ورقة رابحة ،
ماذا ستفعل إذا خسر بشكل جيد
، هذا هو الشيء إذا كان من سيفوز
سيكون رئيستي سأقاتل شخصيًا على المستوى المحلي من
أجل السياسيين المحليين وأعمل معهم
أنا لن أذهب  لتستيقظ حزينة بالنسبة
لي  في يوم آخر ،
علينا فقط أن نستمر في المضي قدمًا ، فأنا مؤيد قوي
لترامب وقد كنت كذلك منذ
سنوات ،
ولكن إذا خسرت وخسرت
بكرامة ، فستربح بكرامة
حيث بدأ الليل في العودة إلى
المنزل على الرغم من أن معظم
لم يتم استدعاء حالات ساحة المعركة حتى الآن ،
ولكن إذا انتظرت قصاصات
الأخبار السارة ، فمتأخرًا تعتقد أنك
ستبقى مستيقظًا
طوال الليل على الأرجح ، فهل تخطط
لأن تحب
القهوة ولا تصلي كثيرًا إذا لم يفعلوا ذلك
.  لدي جميع بطاقات الاقتراع الغيابي ،
أعتقد أن ترامب كان
سيهرب قليلًا. لا أثق في تلك
الحلزونات مرة
واحدة ، إنها 12
49 صباحًا ، هذا هو المكان الذي نحن فيه الآن ،
كان الوقت
مناسبًا ، وماذا عن الانتخابات الحكيمة ، كيف
تشعر حيال  أن
أه هذا ينزل إلى الأسلاك
حفنة من الولايات التي لا
تزال موجودة هناك والتي لا تزال تلعبها ،
وآمل جدًا أن كل شيء سوف يسير في
طريقنا وأن الرئيس ترامب سوف
يسودها
ويعاد انتخابه إيلي ريف سي إن
نيو هدسون ميشيغان